in this intermediate opengl course etai
will teach you about skeletal animation
using 3d models
hi my name is ita and i'd like to
welcome you to a course on skeletal
animation in opengl if you have some
experience with opengl and you want to
learn how to load and animate 3d model
files such as fbx which is used in unity
then this is the course for you the
course is composed of two main sections
in the first one we learn how to load
models using the smp library and the
second section is actually made up of
five parts where we implement skeletal
animation step by step i consider the
material here to be intermediate level
so you should be familiar with the
common three transformations setting up
vertex and index buffers and writing
shaders to do basic lighting if you need
some ramp up on these topics you'll find
beginner level tutorials on my youtube
channel and on my website as well as
resources by other creators as well of
course you'll find links in the video
description below the programming
language of the course is c plus plus so
you should be familiar with it but don't
worry you don't need to be a c plus plus
expert i'm using very basic stuff such
as glasses and no fancy stuff from c
plus 20 or anything like that in terms
of operating system i'm running linux as
my main development to us but you can
also use windows of course you'll find
all the sources in github and i'll
include visual studio solutions as well
so without further ado let's get into it
welcome back to ogl dev i guess it's
quite clear that there is a limit to the
complexity of a manually created model a
pyramid is okay a cube is also okay but
when it comes to modeling something from
the physical world you need some help
there that's why we have software like
blender maya 3ds max and many many other
tools that allow you to create models in
a sophisticated 3d environment with lots
of supporting tools that help the
modeling artists create the amazing 3d
worlds and objects that we are used to
in modern games
the modeling software takes care of
calculating the position texture
coordinates and any other vertex
attributes that you may need it also
groups the vertices into triangles and
manages the corresponding indices
and finally the modeling software saves
all this data to file so you'll be able
to load the model in your game or
application and manipulate it using
opengl or any other 3d api it will
probably not surprise you that since
there are many 3d modelers we also have
lots of formats for the model files
here's a partial list so if you want to
load these model files into your game
you can either write a custom order
yourself or use an existing library for
that if you like writing everything from
scratch then you're welcome to write
such a parser on your own but my
recommendation is to go with an existing
solution because it will save you a lot
of time in this video we're going to use
the open asset import library or simp
which is a free and open source library
that is very easy to use and supports
many file formats snmp takes care of
parsing the model file which by the way
can be text or binary
and loads it into its own native data
structure in memory what we need to do
is to use this data structure in order
to populate opengl vertex and index
buffers load any textures that may also
be present and set up the layout of the
vertex attributes
let's start by installing smp and we
have several options here depending on
the operating system
i'll include the instructions for
everything that you're going to see in
the video description if you're on linux
ubuntu you can simply execute the
following command to install simp
if you want to build smp yourself you'll
need to clone the following repo
cd into the new directory and execute
see make space dot if you don't have
cmake installed you can easily install
it using sudo apt install cmake at this
point you may run into various
difficulties mostly due to missing
packages let me know of any issues in
the comments and i'll try to help as
much as i can you can also use the
support forum on the github page if cma
completed successfully you can execute
make and then sudo make install to
complete the installation
now you need to integrate smp into your
build process as you probably know i'm
using simple bash scripts to build my
sources in these scripts i'm using
package config to get the build and link
parameters so all i need to do is to add
smp as a parameter to the command
package config
flags to get the include directory and
package
config-libs to get the link command the
results of the two commands are provided
as parameters to g
below
package config is very handy because its
behavior is tailored to the distribution
that it is running on which makes it
very flexible on windows you also have
two options you can use the binaries
provided with my source repo or you can
build source yourself unfortunately it
seems that pre-build binaries for
windows are no longer available from the
smp website okay so if you want to use
the binaries that i've created you can
go to the ogl dev directory
go to uh windows down here
and in the leap directory you will find
that this file
smpvc142mt.lib that's the library that
you need to link against it's a release
build of smp and you also
need the dll for runtime which is
in this directory dll it's the same file
just with the extension dll okay and you
will also need all the headers that we
have here at ogl dev slash include we
have simp and that's all the headers
of this library checked in right here
that's the latest version at this time
now if you want to build the sources
yourself you need to check them out
using git i'm using tortoise git and
i've explained how to install it in a
previous tutorial the one about the
windows support so you can find it there
so what you need to do is right click in
sum directory and then git clone
and here's the address of the website
which by default will go to this smp
directory
now i don't need to press ok because i
already got it checked out right here so
let's go inside
and here you can
shift right click and go to
open a powershell window here
and you will also need cmake installs so
just type as cmake
c
make
list
txt
and run it
and it will generate the visual studio
solution file
which we can find right here smp.sln so
let's open this one
and here you can select whether you want
the debug
or the release version
as i said what is checked into the ogl
dev source repo is the release version
and
make sure that you're using x64
and then you just need to do build and
rebuild solution okay
okay the build is complete so we can go
back to snp
lib
and the select debug or release whatever
you use to uh to build
in this case
release so we have this file here which
is exactly the one with which is checked
into the ogl dev source repo and also
in slash bin
we have the dll
okay
okay now go to your project
right click it properties
let's go to linker and input and here in
the additional dependencies we have the
smp lib file
you will also need to make sure that in
c plus plus
general you have the include directory
here as the additional include
directories now i've already got this
directory from uh from all the previous
projects which is going up three
directories and include from the
location of the project okay so if we go
to the location of the visual studio
project file in ogl dev
windows or gl dev vs 2019 we have the
project right here so we're going up
three directories
and here we've got
include and here's the smp headers
when we include the headers we can
simply write this directive right here
because this references
the include directory that we just saw
and we also need to make sure that the
dll file can be accessed during runtime
so let's go to the project properties
again and go to debugging and here we
can see that i've added the location of
the dll directory right here so now we
can run it now let's dive into the code
and i will explain the structure of smp
as we go along okay so first i created a
class called basic mesh that represents
a model loaded using smp
this class is declared in ogldev
basicmash.h in the include directory we
have several public and private
functions here as well as a few private
variables
we'll revisit these items as we go
through the class now let's go to the
implementation of this class in
ogldevbasicmesh.cpp
in the common directory the first
function i'd like to review is load mesh
which is a public function that takes a
file name as a parameter and serves as
the top level entry point for the entire
loading process the first function call
inside this function is to the clear
private function this function clears
all the internal data structure of the
class allowing you to reuse the same
class object for loading a different
model we're not going to use this
capability in this tutorial so i'll just
skip it next we generate and bind the
vertex array object for the current
model we've covered vios in the previous
tutorial so make sure you watch that for
more details next we generate six opengl
buffer objects and buffers is a private
array of six unsigned integers in this
tutorial we're going to see a different
method of storing vertices
what we've been using so far is a method
known as array of structures or aos the
core element in this method is a
structure that contains vertex
attributes such as position texture
coordinates normals etc for storing
multiple vertices we have an array of
this structure
hence the name array of structures this
array is loaded into the opengl buffer
which means that the attributes are
interleaved there in the exact same way
as in cpu memory the second method and
the one that i'm going to demonstrate
today is a structure of arrays or soa
here we have a separate array for each
of the attributes okay so we have an
array of positions array of textual
coordinates and so on we can group these
arrays together in a single structure
hence the name structure of arrays the
arrays must all be of the same length so
in order to access all the attributes of
a single vertex we need to use the same
index to access each of the arrays
opengl allows us to use both methods to
build up our 3d objects we use an enum
to access each buffer by its name rather
than an obscure number so the first
buffer is the index buffer we have the
position at index 1 texture coordinates
at index 2 and normal at index 3. normal
vectors are required for lighting
effects for now this is just a
placeholder so if you're writing this
code yourself you can drop it the last
two buffers wvp mat vb and world map vb
are also placeholders they will be used
in the future when we get to instance
sync back to load mesh we can see that
we're initializing all the buffers in a
single call to glgen buffers by the way
array size in elements is a handy macro
for calculating the number of elements
in an array by dividing the size of the
array by the size of the first element
which must always exists in order to
access the services of smp we define an
object of the importer class which is
defined in the smp namespace to get this
compiled we must include three files
from the smp include directory
importer.hpp scene.h and postprocess.h
to actually load the model we call
importer.read file passing in the model
file name and the list of smp flags
which is wrapped inside this smp load
flags macro these flags allow us to
modify the behavior of snp so let's
quickly go over them first we have the
triangulate flag
many modeling tools allow you to build
models using polygons with more than
three vertices we must use triangles so
this flag tells smp to split these
polygons into triangles
gen smooth normals is for lighting so
let's keep it for now
flip uv flips the texture coordinates
along the v or the y axis of the texture
this is something that you may need to
play with to make this work with your
models because some modelers will allow
you to control this when exporting the
model
and finally we want snmp to join
identical vertices and adjust the index
buffer accordingly this will save us
some memory there are many more flags
available in the smp post process.h
header and you can find the full
documentation online this is actually
one of the reasons why smp is so
flexible if read file returns null then
the call has failed and we print the
error using importer.geterrorstring
else we get back a pointer to an object
of the aicin class and we call init from
scene to continue the initialization
aicin is the top level data structure in
the memory representation of the model
that snmp created as usual before we
leave this function we unbind our vao
from the opengl state now let's continue
with init from scene which is defined
below this function the way that the ai
scene is structured is that it matches
the behavior of most modelers that
enable you to split up the model into
sub-components this allows you to apply
some transformation on one component
without affecting the others so you can
have a head an arm a sword and whatever
if the model is split into
sub-components snmp creates an ai mesh
structure for each component this ai
mesh contains all the vertices and
indices of that component the number of
ai mesh structures is given in the m num
meshes variable of the aicin class we
reserve a matching number of elements in
our private variable meshes which is a
vector of basic mesh entry basic mesh
entry contains a few variables that we
will need to maintain for each ai mesh
such as the number of vertices base
vertex etc we're going to see these soon
a scene can also contain textures and
smp wraps one or more textures in
something which it calls materials these
are stored in an array of ai material
structures and the size of this array is
given in m num materials we have a
matching vector of pointers to our
texture class so we reserve space there
accordingly
now here's the plan we're going to stack
up all the vertices and indices from all
the ai mesh structures in the buffers
we've just created according to their
type index position texture coordinates
etc however each ai mesh may use a
different texture but we can switch
textures in the middle of a draw core
this means that we need to launch a draw
call for each ai mesh separately and
this will give us the opportunity to
switch textures as needed between draw
calls this also means that we cannot use
gel draw elements because this function
only draws vertices from the beginning
of the buffer we need a more
sophisticated function that allows us to
draw from different offsets within the
buffer and opengl provides us with such
a draw function okay so in order to
actually allocate space in our index and
vertex buffers we need to know how many
vertices and indices there are in the
entire scene object unfortunately these
are not readily available to us so we
need to actually count them we do this
in the private function count vertices
and indices which also updates the
meshes array we just need to loop over
the elements in the meshes array that
we've just resized for each element we
copy the material index from the
corresponding a mesh we calculate the
number of indices in the current mesh by
multiplying the number of faces by 3
since after triangulation all the
polygons are now triangles the base
vertex is the index of the first vertex
of the current mesh in our global
buffers to calculate it we increment num
vertices by the number of vertices in
the ai mesh
we calculate the base index in a similar
fashion by incrementing num indices by
the number of indices of the current
mesh that we've just calculated so for
example if we have three meshes with 100
250 vertices then the first mesh is at
offset 0. the second mesh is at offset
100 and the last one is at offset 300.
when we exit the function both num
vertices and numerators contain the
totals for each type when we're back to
init from scene we call reserve space
with the two counters this function
allocates space in four vectors for the
positions texture coordinates normals
and indices these vectors are private
members of the class they will be used
to accumulate all the vertices from the
aic in structure so we can load each
opengl buffer with a single call to gl
buffer data back to load mesh we call
init all meshes which simply traverses
all the simp mesh structures and calls
in each single match for each one in
this function we actually populate the
vectors that we just saw with vertex and
index data we do this by going over all
the vertices in the ai mesh and
extracting the position normal and
texture coordinates from their
respective location in the ai mesh
notice that these items are represented
by snmp ai vector 3d which is very
similar to our vector class in the case
of the texture coordinate we must also
check that it exists and if not use a
zero vector instead we can now populate
our vectors with this data also notice
that in the case of the texture
coordinates we only use the x and y out
of the 3d vector
populating the indices is very similar
the ia mesh contains an array of
triangles called m faces each ai phase
structure contains three indices which
we need to push into the indices vector
the next function that you need from syn
calls is init materials this is where we
allocate gl textures for the images in
the model the image files are stored in
the same directory as the main model
file so first we need to extract the
directory of the model file this is done
by simple parsing of the last slash
character we can now reverse the
materials array in the smp scene
material is basically a container for
multiple textures and it may contain
diffuse specular and ambient textures as
well as stuff like a height map normal
map and etc these are required for more
advanced stuff like lighting for basic
texturing we just need the diffuse
texture so we check whether it exists by
calling get texture on the material with
the ai texture type underscore diffuse
enum in the first parameter the second
parameter is 0 because we only want the
first texture the third parameter is an
address of an ai string variable where
the path of the texture will be returned
if it exists of course right now we
don't need the rest of the parameters so
we have nulls there if the call was
successful we construct the full path of
the texture file inside the model the
path of the texture is relative to the
location of the model file now we can
create our texture object as usual and
load it let's go back to init from scene
for the last time and the final call
here is to the private function populate
buffers and this is where we prepare
stuff for using soa we start by binding
the position buffer to the glra buffer
target to make it current we load the
data from the vector into the buffer by
calling geobuffer data the number of
bytes is obtained by multiplying the
size of the first element by the number
of elements in the vector the base
address is the address of the first
element and we use geostatic draw
because we don't plan on updating the
buffer again next we enable the vertex
attribute for the position at the top of
this file we have macros for the
location of the three vertex attributes
it's not the most robust design because
we must keep this in sync with the
shader but it will do for now next we
configure the layout of the position
buffer by calling gl vertex 3 pointer
again we use the macro for the index of
the attribute we have three floats here
jail false for no need to normalize and
the last two parameters are now zero
previously we had to put here the size
of the entire vertex structure and the
offset of the current attribute inside
the vertex since the positions are
packed one after the other we can now
put zeros here because the driver
already knows everything from the three
floats we repeat the same process for
the textural coordinates and the normals
and every time we call gl vertex a
3-pointer the driver stores the address
of the buffer which is currently bound
to gl array buffer for the current
attribute this enables each attribute to
come from a different buffer okay so soa
structure of arrays finally we populate
the indices just remember to use gl
element array buffer for the target here
congratulations we are done with
uploading the model the only thing that
we have left here is of course the
render function we start by binding the
va of this model this brings in the
vertex layout that we've just created
next we reverse our internal meshes
array we get the material index and we
check whether we have a corresponding
element in the textural array because
there may be a material without a
diffuse texture if there is a texture we
bind it color texture unit is simply a
macro for gl texture 0 that i keep in
ogldev engine common.h i'm using this
file in order to keep the tutorial
somewhat consistent now comes the
interesting part instead of gel draw
elements we use gl draw elements base
vertex that allows us to draw
sub-regions of the vertex and index
buffers the first parameter is gl
triangles as usual the second parameter
is the number of indices of the current
mesh which we've calculated when we
loaded the model
next is the data type of the index
unsignedint in our case
next is the offset to the first index of
the current mesh in the index buffer so
we multiply the base index of the
current mesh by the size of an unsigned
int in order to get the offset we also
need to cast it to void pointer i think
this is due to some historical issue
with this function
the last parameter is the base vertex
for the current draw call you see the
original indices that we got from simp
started at zero in each ai mesh
structure but we decided to stack up all
the vertices in a single buffer per
attribute this messes up the indexing
one solution would be to adjust each
index based on the starting position of
the mesh
in our single buffer a more simple
solution is to use this last parameter
here as a base vertex
this number will be added to each index
so that it will match the offset inside
our buffer
for example let's say that we have two
ai meshes the indices of both meshes
start at zero
but each mesh obviously refers to its
own set of vertices we stack up the two
vertex groups one after the other and
let's say that the size of the first
group is a hundred
so the base vertex for the second group
will be calculated as a hundred when we
render the second group we will pass in
a hundred in this last parameter so that
index zero will become a hundred index
one will become a hundred and one and
etc so we have a subset of indices that
start at some offset inside the index
buffer and to each index opengl will
automatically add whatever we put as the
base vertex
all these elements were already
calculated when loading the model so
they are now ready when we get here okay
so we have a series of draw calls here
each draw call uses a subset of the
index and vertex buffers and before each
draw call we have an opportunity to
switch textures now let's see the
changes in the main application code in
the tutorial 18 class i got rid of all
the vbos vios and index buffer that i
used to keep around here as well as the
world transform object instead we just
need a single pointer to basic mesh
in the init method we need to call load
mesh with the path of the model file in
the main render function we perform all
the transformations on the world trans
object that we have in the basic mesh
class so if we have multiple meshes it
makes it simple to keep the
transformation of each mesh inside its
own object
also instead of calling jail draw
elements we just need to call the render
function on the mesh object this is
basically all we need to do here now
let's build and run this
okay so this looks like a spider but
there's obviously something wrong here
right the problem is that i haven't
enabled the depth test without it the
frame buffer works like a regular canvas
so whatever color you use last that's
the color that you're actually going to
get on the final screen with simple
stuff like the cube we couldn't see the
problem but with more complex models the
problem is evident i discussed the depth
buffer in a previous episode so i won't
repeat it here by enabling the depth
test we make sure that the closest pixel
is rendered regardless the order of
rendering we do this by calling gl
enable with the geo depth test macro as
a parameter we must also clear the depth
buffer on every frame else it will
contain garbage data from the previous
frame so in the main render function we
add the gl depth buffer bit with the
bitmask that we provide to the jail
clear call okay guys you can now go
ahead and try to load different models
that you find for free online or that
you create yourself if you know how i
can't guarantee that this code is
bulletproof and will work for every
model it probably still contains some
bugs please let me know if you run into
a problem
welcome back to ogl dev
in this tutorial we're starting to take
a look at skeletal animation and how to
implement it in opengl skeletal
animation or skinning
is considered the standard way of
animating almost any living creature and
it can also be used to animate monsters
aliens as well as various types of types
of machines such as robots therefore it
is a core technique in game development
so over the course of the next few
tutorials we're going to do a deep dive
into it simp the library that we've been
using to load models has very good
support for skeletal animation across
several file types so we will take
advantage of it the way that i'm going
to cover this subject is going to be
very hands-on oriented i'll provide an
overview of the process and the
technique and then we'll basically jump
back and forth between the code and the
theory we'll understand some part of the
algorithm and then see how to implement
it in c plus using opengl and then back
to theory and etc i'm going to use
blender as the modeling tool so for
simplicity i'll just use the name
blender but of course
all the other major modeling tools
support skeletal animation as well just
to clarify i'm not an artist but for the
purpose of developing this mini series i
did spend some time studying blender
because i think that the
familiarity with the tool where you
create and animate the model gives you
better art better understanding
of the developer part in this process
now let's take the human body as an
example as you are probably aware 70
percent of our body is water which is
why we are so flexible the bones are
wrapped by flesh and the flesh is
wrapped by the skin so basically you can
say that the skin is carried or held
by the bones now this is not going to be
a lesson in anatomy all i'm saying is
that the idea behind skeletal animation
is pretty much borrowed from the real
world all the models that we've been
using so far have been simply the
exterior representation of a real-world
object inside the object there is
nothing so in the context of skeletal
animation
we call the model itself the skin
which is why this technique is also
called skinning the bones are the
skeleton which kind of carries the skin
like in the real world but since we
don't have any flesh in our model
between the skeleton and the skin the
replacement that the blender provides is
simply a list of vertices that are
affected by each bone this means that
when the bone is animated or to put it
in a language which is more common to us
when it is translated and rotated the
same transformation which is applied to
the bone must be applied on the vertices
that are affected by it for example when
the bone of an arm is translated and
rotated the part of the mesh that
represents that arm is translated and
rotated to follow the movement and
rotation of the bone calculating the
transformations that must be applied on
the vertices due to the movement of the
bones is the major goal of this
technique it is important to understand
that only the skin gets rendered and not
a skeleton the job of the skeleton and
the bones is simply to help us define
the range of movement that is available
to the skin for example the angle
between the arm and the forearm can
range between zero uh quote unquote when
the two limbs touch each other and then
the 180 degrees when the forearm is
fully stretched
beyond that the elbow will break
not nice the processing blender of
placing the virtual bones inside the
skin
making them in the proper length to fit
the specific body part and connecting
them together into a skeleton is called
rigging skinning is the process where
you connect the vertices to the skeleton
and define the amount by which each
vertex is affected by the bones the last
piece of the puzzle is animating and
this is where you use the available
controls placed during the rigging phase
in order to create a set of keyframes
that define the movement of the bow of
the bones over time skeletal animation
has two main characteristics that help
us mimic the real world movement first
the skeleton defines the hierarchy of
bones
most bones will have a parent so when
the parent bone moves the child bone
follows
this relationship is one way the child
may move without affecting the parent
second
each vertex may be affected by more than
one bone
this means that when one or more bones
move the transformation of the vertices
that are influenced by these bones must
somehow combine the transformations of
each bone actually
if you have a model where every vertex
is fully controlled by a single bone
then that model is probably that of a
robot or any other type of machine a car
is a simple example you can use skeletal
animation to animate the opening and
closing of car doors
the door is connected to the car by some
kind of a metal joint but when the door
opens the only vertices that are moving
belong to the door the rest of the car
stays exactly where it is this is
definitely not the case with living
creatures here we want the model to
deform in a way that will simulate the
elasticity of the skin
this behavior is most evident around the
joints skeletal animation allows us a
high degree of flexibility in terms of
calculating the movement of each vertex
based on all the bones that affect it we
do this by assigning a weight to each
combination of a bone and a vertex the
weight is a fraction between 0 and 1
and the sum of all weights per vertex
should be 1. we do the calculation as a
linear combination
of the bone transformations and their
weights for example
if the weight of two bones affecting one
vertex is a half
it means that the vertex is equally
influenced by both bones and its
movement will be the average of the
movement of the two bones if one weight
is 0.9 and the other is 0.1 it means
that the vertex is probably much closer
to the first bone so it will go along
with it but there will still be some
minor influence coming in from the
second bone that may pull it a bit
towards a different direction blender
provides the artist with powerful tools
to set the weights of the different
bones
most artists will probably start with an
automatic assignment of weights in this
method blender calculates the weights
based on the distance between the vertex
and each bone the next step will be to
review the result and start fixing and
adjusting and tuning the model using
weight painting
weight painting is a featuring blender
where you increase or decrease the
weights of vertices for the selected
bone
by going over them with a special brush
usually the artist will develop the skin
first and then structure the skeleton
inside it it makes sense because the
bones must match the dimension of the
body part that will actually get
rendered
at this stage before the animation
process is started the posture of the
skin is called bind pose this is very
important
because all the underlying
transformations and math will reference
the bind pose as a starting position
there are no restrictions in terms of
how the model should look like in bind
pose
but the common practice is to keep the
model in this kind of relaxed posture
without too many bendings in the area of
the joints if you search for skeletal
animation bind pose in google images you
will find many examples of this posture
for the human or semi-human models with
the arms kind of stretched to the sides
and the legs are straight and relaxed
when you render the model without
applying any animation on it you should
get it in bind pose once rigging and
skinning have been completed the model
is ready for animation
naturally the same set of bones can be
used for multiple sets of animation
think about all the possibilities the
human body provides in terms of movement
and flexibility all this is achieved
with just 206 bones
even with a small subset of these bones
in a human model you can still implement
many animations
therefore each animation set will
simulate some kind of an activity such
as walking running
fighting etc an animation set
is composed of a series of
transformations that are applied on the
skeleton as the artist animates it
these transformations may include as
usual scaling rotation and translation
in the case of humans and many other
living creatures we will only encounter
rotation and translation but the
technique itself can support animated
scaling of bones as well the
transformations will be provided at
regular intervals according to some
frame rate for example a 10 second
animation at 24 frames per second will
include 240 sets of transformations
these sets are usually very close
so if the actual frame rate in the game
is higher than the animation frame rate
we can interpolate between consecutive
transformations and get a finer
animation since these transformations
represent the changes in the orientation
of the bones we can apply them on the
vertices that are influenced by these
bones and basically animate the model
okay this is enough theory for now i've
left out many details that we will need
for the full implementation but at this
stage i'd like to get our hands dirty
with some code now skeletal animation is
supported by various file types and if
you implement a loader for a specific
file type you will probably need your
skeletal animation code to adhere to the
conventions of that file type however
since we are using smp we only need our
code to advert to the conventions and
specifics of this library and by that
we'll be able to support many file types
as i said we're going to implement this
technique step by step in a hands-on
approach so let's create a simple
utility that will parse the data
structures created by smp and extract
the relevant parts from it later we will
incorporate this logic into our opengl
application now this utility is not
required for the actual execution of the
animation but will be very useful for
debugging etc
so this utility is composed of a single
file which i called snmp sandbox cpp and
we've also got a build script in the
same directory called the build smp
sandbox
to build it and it is very simple we
have the build flags right here called
cpp flags and for now i've included only
dash
ggdb3 in order to build it with debug
information for debugging and we've also
got the link flags called ldflags which
is a call to
config dash dash libs
smp i'm often using package config in my
build script
in order for my code to hopefully
compile on as many machines and systems
as possible okay so if you run this on
the command line
package config dash dash libs smp
in this case on my machine it tells you
that the link command is dash l smp and
on other systems it may generate
a different command okay and the final
build command is very simple we call g
plus plus the name of the cpp file
uh the compile flags the link flags dash
o and the name of the binary okay so now
let's take a look at the cpp file
and by the way i have a video on loading
models using smp so definitely check
that out if you want more details i'll
go over the major details
in this video okay so first we need to
include
these three headers for smp
okay
let's scroll down to the bottom and here
we have
your standard main function we're
checking the number of parameters here
and it needs to be two because there's a
single parameter to this utility which
is the model file name okay
so if that's not the case we simply
exit the utility next we pick up the
file name
from location 1 in the arc v array and
we define an object of the smp importer
class
which basically handles all the smp
parsing stuff next we call read file on
the importer object using the file name
and the load flag for smp which i
defined for convenience right here and
this is pretty standard we've done this
already triangulate all the polygons in
the mesh generate
normals and join identical vertices we
check for error
and we call parsine using the returned
aicin object from read file so aac is
the main object that handles all our
interaction with smp and it has several
interesting functions
as well as members that we can access in
this case we're going
directly to the to the meshes okay there
is array an array of a.i mesh object
which is where all the vertices live
and the indices as well as the bones so
parsine is very simple it just calls the
parse meshes
with the scene object and in the future
we will have a function to handle the
hierarchy
and the animations okay so this will
grow and develop over the next few
tutorials so we have parse meshes here
and we start by printing the number of
meshes in the scene object
which you can find in the m num meshes
attribute in the scene next we prepare a
few counters
for the total number of vertices in the
season bones
we loop over the number of meshes and we
extract each mesh
from the m meshes array based on the
index
we take the number of vertices
we calculate the number of indices which
is the number of faces time 3 because
we've triangulated all the polygons and
we also access
num bones okay so in the ai mesh
structure
we have an array of bones
right here
and we have the number of bones
in this attribute m num bones next we
calculate the total number of vertices
indices and bones
which we're going to print at the end of
this function and this is mostly for
informative purposes just to make sure
that every everything is working
correctly the important piece is here
what we call has bones which is a
boolean function that tells us whether
this mesh has any bones in it and then
we call par smash bones on the specific
mesh that we're currently processing so
now let's go to par smash bones which is
up here and this is also very simple we
loop over the number of bones in this
mesh and we call parse single bone now
if we run this right now and i'll use a
model which is checked into my repo
called the bob lamp clean md5 mesh which
is by the way from doom 3
and you can see that it tells us that
there are six meshes
and these are the names of the meshes
okay we have a body
a face a helmet grill grill and um
another body
and for each mesh we can see the number
of vertices and then this is and this is
the important thing here the number of
bones okay so the body has 28 bones
and the face has just two bones and
these guys have one bone and the last
one
has two bones okay and if we load it in
blender we can actually see right here
on the right hand side
that these meshes correspond to
components of the mesh inside blender so
we have the grill which this guy is
holding and we have the body
okay
and this part of the body is actually
the sword the face and the helmet okay
so now let's see
parse mesh bones which is right here and
this is a simple loop over the number of
bones
in the mesh and we're calling par single
bone
for each bone from this array and we'll
also we're also passing in
the index of the bone which we will
later see so let's see what we have in
this ai bone structure and there are
only four public attributes okay we have
the name of the bone which is used for
informative purposes as you saw in
blender you want to name the bone so
you'll be able to remember what it's
supposed to do and we have the number of
weights here which is actually
the number of elements in this array and
weights okay we'll see that in a second
we have an attribute called m offset
matrix which is a four by four matrix
and it tells us that this matrix
transforms
from mesh space to bone space in bind
pose okay so this may sound a bit
intimidating
but we will see how to use that in a
future video and the last attribute is
the m weights array
which is of the ai vertex weight
structure and this structure contains
just two attributes okay so every
element in the structure has a vertex id
which tells us the index of the vertex
that is influenced by this bone and the
strength of that influence
which must be in the range 0 to 1 as we
talked about earlier so in the par
single bone function
we loop over the number of weights in
the bone and we extract
the vertex weight element from the m
weights array and let me just uncomment
all these printf calls
we're basically printing the vertex id
and the weight now let's run this again
and now we're getting the list of bones
for each mesh as well as the vertices
that are influenced by it okay so here
we can see
that the first bone bone zero is called
pubis and the number of vertices
affected by this bone is 190 and here we
can see
all the all the indices of these
vertices as well as their weights okay
so we can see that
this model is actually very simple so
when we glance through this it seems
like
when a vertex is influenced by two bones
then the weight of each bone will be a
half and if it is influenced by three
bones
then the weight will be
a third okay so always the weight for
each bone will be the same as the other
bones okay so it averages out and here's
the next bone which is pelvis 254
vertices then the spine and it continues
like that
so the total number of bones is 35 this
brings us to the first challenge each
bone is mapped to the vertices that it
influences and many vertices are
influenced by multiple bones
but skeletal animation is implemented
in the vertex shader because this is
basically the only place
where we can actually change the
position of vertex
therefore what we really need is a
reversed mapping from each vertex to the
bones that influence it
this info must be provided to the vertex
shader so that we can calculate the
transformation of each vertex based on
all these bones
all this and more will be covered in the
next tutorial
[Music]
okay quick recap from part one we
created a small utility to load the bone
related stuff from smp
snmp holds the model in one or more mesh
structures and each mesh
points to an array of bones and each
bone points to an array of the vertices
that it influences for each vertex we
have an index and a weight which is a
floating point number between
0 and 1 that represents the amount by
which the current bone
influences this vertex at the end of
part 1 i left you with the challenge of
mapping the vertices back to the bones
that influenced them
okay so maybe i was a bit too dramatic
anyway this video is going to be very
technical and the focus will be on
implementing this mapping and making
sure that it is working correctly now
since the core principle in this
mini-series is to work in a step-by-step
fashion
we're going to implement it first in the
smp utility and then move this logic
over to the main application
i also want to visualize the relation
between the bones and the vertices so in
today's demo you'll be able to actually
see the effect that each bone has over
the vertices
in this example the red triangles
represent vertices that are highly
influenced by the current bone and this
influence decreases as we move from red
to yellow and then to green the blue
triangles represent vertices that don't
receive any influence from the current
bone you can click the space bar and
switch between the different bones this
part of the fragment shader is not
required in the final implementation but
i think that if you are implementing
this in your own code it will be a good
debugging step just to make sure that
everything is loaded correctly into the
gpu okay so let's jump back into smp
sandbox.cpp
and we start by including the map string
and vector headers from the c plus plus
standard library for the data structures
that we will need here next we have a
macro which defines the maximum number
of bones per vertex four balls is enough
for my model so just tweak this to make
it match your assets next we have the
vertex bone data structure that contains
two arrays
one for the indices of all the bones
that affect this vertex and for each
bone we also have a corresponding weight
i'll skip the rest of this structure for
now next we have three new data
structures we have a vector of the
vertex bone data for each vertex this is
basically the mapping from the vertices
back to the bones that influence them we
have a vector of integers called mesh
base vertex the snp scene class contains
meshes which contain bones and each bone
references the vertices of the mesh in
which it is contained as if they start
at zero
we're going to pack all the vertices
together in a single array called vertex
to bones so we want to map the relative
vertex index to a unique global vertex
index and we do that by calculating a
base vertex for each mesh and adding the
relative vertex index to this base
finally we have a map from bone names to
their indices because snmp uses strings
for the name of the bones but for us it
will be much more straightforward to
work with bone indices so now let's jump
down to main and we've seen this in part
one so very briefly
main calls parsine which calls for
smashes and here we resize mesh base
vertex
using the number of meshes in the scene
so for each mesh we have a base index
which we need to calculate
and
we do this right here
the total number of vertices is
increased for each mesh so before we
increase it for the current mesh we save
the current total number of vertices as
the base we also resize vertex to bones
based on the updated total number of
vertices because we're going to need
this space when we parse the mesh now
this is not the most efficient way to do
this
but for a utility like that this is okay
basically this vector is resized again
and again for each new mesh with just
enough space for this mesh
finally we call parsmesh bones and you
may notice that i added the index of the
current mesh because we're going to need
it later
parsmesh bones didn't change we simply
call par single bone for each bone with
the addition of the mesh index in the
first parameter in part 1 this function
simply printed all the vertices that are
affected by the current bone and their
weights i added some code here to create
the mapping from the vertices back to
the bones
first we get the bone id
which is a unique index for each bone
inside the loop we calculate the global
vertex id by adding the vertex id from
the ai vertex weight structure to the
base vertex id of the current mesh which
we set in the parse meshes function
right here
each mesh has a batch of vertices and
the bones that reference them use
indices that start at zero we want to
stack up all the indices of all these
batches together one after the other
because we're loading it like that to
the vertex buffer so we have to make
these indices unique so the first batch
starts at 0 and then the base of the
next batch starts with wherever the
previous batch ended let's jump to get
bone id which maps the name of the bone
to its unique index we have a map
between a string and an integer called
bone name to index map if the name
already exists we just return the index
and if not we set the mapping and the
bone id simply increments automatically
as we add more items into the map back
to par single mesh
now that we have the global vertex id we
use it to access the vertex to bones
array which i remind you is a vector of
vertex bond data structure and we call
add bond data with the index of the
current bond and the weight which is
coming from the ai vertex weight
structure this function searches for a
free slot in the weights array and
places the bone id and the weight in
that slot we assume that if the weight
is zero then this slot is free because
the weight must be greater than zero if
the bone actually influences that vertex
once we find the free slot and do the
update we can exit the function if we
can't find a free slot there will be an
assertion because either you have a bug
or you need to increment the maximum
number of bones per vertex now let's run
this
on our boblam
clean.md5 mesh file
and you can see that we get the vertex
id
the bone index the weight and the index
of the slot where this info was recorded
let's do a bit of oak magic let's grab
vertex and have oak print just the
values in this line okay so we have the
vertex id at index 3
bone index at 5
wait at 7 and slot at 9.
works ok
we can sort this numerically by the
vertex ids and we can see that the first
vertex is fully influenced by bone
number two
the second vertex is influenced by bones
two and three and we got their weights
at slot 0 and 1. so this makes sense
vertex 8 is influenced by 11 2 and 3 so
this looks ok as well
if you want you can check this more
thoroughly but i think that
for now it is ok the next step will be
to integrate this piece of logic into
our opengl application and actually load
the indices and weights of the bonus per
vertex into a vertex buffer we can then
access it from the vertex shader and do
cool stuff like applying some color to
all the pixels that are affected by a
certain bone again this is just for
debugging but we're making progress in
small steps and making sure at each step
that everything is working correctly is
very helpful
for the integration i copied ogl dev
basic mesh header and cpp files into
this directory and i renamed them
skinnedmash.h and cpp the next tutorial
will include a new version of the same
files in its own directory so you'll be
able to compare the two revisions ogl
dev basic mesh was already covered in a
previous tutorial i'll put a link below
to that video right now we'll just cover
the scaled animation related code this
class is called the skinned mesh same as
the header and here we have the max
number of bones per vertex
vertex bone data is here as a private
declaration and it is the same one as in
the sandbox so no need to go over it
we're going to use a new vertex buffer
for the bones in addition to the index
position texture coordinates and normal
so we have a new enum for the bone
vertex buffer we have the declarations
of three functions that i simply copied
from the sandbox as is load mesh bones
load single bone and get bone id i use
the word load instead of parse because
it is more common in this class we have
a vector of vertex bond data again same
as the sandbox
we're going to use it to populate the
vertex buffer of the bones and finally
the map between the bone name and its
index now let's go to the cpp file we
have two new vertex attribute locations
for the vertex shader this will allow
each vertex to access its list of bones
and the weights make sure to keep these
numbers synchronized with the vertex
shader in the reserve space function
we are resizing the bone vector based on
the number of bones okay so this is the
same as all the other buffers here in
init single mesh
i added a call to load mesh bones which
calls load single bones which uses get
bone id to map the name of the bone to
its index okay so again this works the
same as in the smp utility basically
when the processing of the scene
structure is complete we have all the
mapping from the vertices to bones in
this m bones vector and then in the
populate buffers function we bind and
allocate the new bone vertex buffer
we also enable the two vertex attributes
to access the bone ids and weights we
also need to set the layout correctly
so for the bone ids make sure to use
glint and not gel float as all the other
attributes we have four integers for the
four ids
followed by four floats make sure to set
the offset correctly for the second
attribute we have the max number of
bones times the size of a bone id so we
should get 16 bytes here okay
four bonds times four bytes per integer
now we want to make sure that the bone
vertex buffer is populated and loaded
correctly so in this demo we will paint
the triangles that are affected by each
bone using a specific color let's see
how to do that in the vertex shader we
have two new input attributes for the
bone ids and the weights
notice that the ids are ivac and not a
regular vac the regular vac is for
floating points and the ids are integers
so we must use ivec the vertex shader
simply copies the two attributes out to
the fragment shader so we also need to
declare them as output attributes here
we meet the type qualifier flat for the
first time
we're used to having the rasterizer
interpolate attributes such as colors
and texture coordinates across the
triangle face but in the case of the
bone ids it doesn't make any sense so
this flat qualifier basically tells the
rasterizer don't interpolate simply copy
the attribute as is we have a
corresponding declaration in the
fragment shader and we must use flat
here as well
if we forget it we will get an error
that says that integer varying must be
flat the rest of the fragment shader
will simply copy it from a previous
tutorial on lighting and the only change
is in the main function
we loop over the number of bones and we
check each slot in the bone ids
attribute
whether this is equal to display bone
index which is a uniform attribute set
by the application we're going to see
that in a minute
if this is true we want to set the
output color and here i try to mimic the
behavior of blender
okay so in blender if you go to wind
paint mode you can switch between the
vertex groups which is basically the
bones
and then the blue vertices are not
affected by the selected bone at all
the red is highly affected and the green
and yellow are somewhere in between i
try to do a similar thing in the
fragment shader okay it's not perfect
but it's pretty usable
if the weight of the current bone is
more than 0.7 we output red modulated by
the weight because it looks like blender
also uses the way to interpolate the
color between point four and point six
we use green and then yellow for
anything else above point one if the
bone index is not found for this pixel
we use blue i also multiply the original
color that comes from lighting by a
small fraction
in order to disable its effect i didn't
use zero so that the compiler will not
yell at me that the lighting stuff is
not really used the application code is
pretty standard so no need to go over
everything the only thing to note here
is that when spacebar is pressed we
increment the current display bone index
we use modulo to make sure we don't
overflow the number of bones and then we
set this index into the fragment shader
the fragment shader has a uniform
integer for this index and this is what
we use
for checking the bone id
now let's see how this works
so the next step is to understand the
matrices that control the transformation
of the vertices during the animation
all this and more will be covered in the
next tutorial
[Music]
in parts 1 and 2 we learned how to load
the skeleton information using the smp
library and we created a mapping so that
each vertex can access the bones that
influence it along with the weights we
verify the implementation using a simple
demo that shows the triangles that are
influenced by selected bone in this
video we're going to study the core
transformations of the skeletal
animation technique remember that in
part 1 we talked about how you create
the appearance of animation in blender
using a set of keyframes where you
adjust the location and orientation of
the bones in each keyframe now if this
was a job interview and i asked you well
given the way that blender works how
would you implement animation in general
then i guess that off the top of your
head you know you could say that you can
save the position of all the vertices in
each frame and then during run time
simply render a different set of
vertices in each frame well i guess this
would work
but you can obviously see the downsides
of this approach this will probably blow
up your model files as well as your
vertex buffer or buffers therefore the
approach taken by the actual algorithm
is to save a single set of positions
specifically in bind pose that we talked
about in part one
in addition we associate a set of
transformations with each bone one
transformation for each keyframe during
runtime we perform a weighted average of
all the transformations that affect each
vertex
in practice smp actually saves the
transformations as separate items one
vector for scaling another vector for
translation and a quaternion for the
rotation we already know how to create
transformation matrices from these guys
so no problem there we only need to
figure out how to apply these matrices
on the model because it's not that
straightforward there is an additional
complexity from the fact that we want a
parent bone to affect the child bone but
not the reverse so if the finger moves
it doesn't affect the hand but when the
hand moves obviously the fingers also
move to understand how all this works we
need to introduce a new coordinate
system called the bone coordinate system
or bone space the origin of the bone
coordinate system is at the base of the
bone the bone itself points along the y
axis and the x and z axis are
perpendicular to the y axis and to each
other of course you can turn on the
display of this coordinate system in
blender by selecting the armature in the
outlier going into object data
properties tab and inside viewport
display you have a checkbox called axis
we know that in general the vertices of
a mesh are specified in reference to a
local coordinate system so what is the
relationship between the local
coordinate system and the bone
coordinate system
well the bones form a hierarchy which is
a simple graph there is a root at the
top and every node has zero or more
children
every node except the root has a single
parent
when rigging a new model the artist will
designate some bone at the core of the
model as the root the remaining bones
will branch out from this root and from
each other in the case of a simple human
model it makes sense to use the spine as
the root and then the immediate children
will be the four limbs and the neck from
there you can continue down to the
fingers the bone space of the root is
specified in reference to the local
space so you can think about the local
space as a primary coordinate system
with the origin at 0 0 0 and the axis
are as usual 1 0 0 0 1 0 and 0 0 1. the
base of the root bone will be some point
in this system same as the regular
vertices and the root bone axis will be
vectors in this system in the following
2d example the origin of the bone space
of the root is located at 1 on the x and
one on the y and the bone space axes are
some arbitrary unit vectors things
become a bit more complex when we move
from the root of the hierarchy to its
immediate children the bone space of the
children are defined in reference to the
root rather than the local space going
back to a 2d example we can see the root
of the hierarchy at one on the x and one
on the y and the base of the child bone
is also
at one of the x and one on the y but in
reference to its parent which is the
root in reference to local space the
child bone is actually located at two on
the x and two on the y in this example i
made the axis of the two bone spaces
aligned with the axis of local space to
make it easier for me to calculate
everything in my head but obviously it
doesn't have to be this way by defining
each bone space as a reference to its
parent we can create a chain of
transformations that goes from each bone
back to the root of the hierarchy a
change in the transformation of a node
will obviously affect all of its
descendants but not its parents if you
need an intuition for how this works you
can take the model of the universe as an
example
you can trace the orbit of the moon
around the earth in a coordinate system
which is centered on the earth the
parent of this coordinate system is
obviously the one where the earth orbits
around the sun so if you want to
calculate the location of the moon in
reference to the sun you need to take
its coordinates in the original system
and multiply it by transformation from
the original system
to the coordinate system where the sun
is at the origin the next step will be
to multiply the result with the
transformation from the sun coordinate
system to the coordinate system where
the sun orbits around the center of the
galaxy or something like that the final
transformation will be from the galaxy
coordinate system to the universe
coordinate system and this will give you
the coordinates of the moon in the
universe so i'm not sure if professional
astronomers will approve this model but
i think that for us it is okay going
back to the bones
the process in skeletal animation begins
by transforming the position of a vertex
which is given as usual in local space
while the model is in bind pose to the
coordinate system of a bone that
influences it from there we transform it
to the bone space of the parent and we
continue until we get to the root of the
hierarchy at the end of the process we
are back at local space which is where
the route is defined and we can continue
to world and view space as usual now
there is a small twist here with smp
known as the global inverse transform
which you may have heard of and i will
talk about it later since each vertex is
often influenced by more than one bone
we actually need to do a weighted
average of the transformations of
several bones each bone transformation
will be calculated in the same way by
going back from the bone all the way to
the root in addition to that we also
need to tweak the transformation of each
node as time progresses otherwise there
won't be any movement
to actually implement this process smp
provides us with two matrices the first
one is called the offset matrix and it
is part of the bone structure which also
contains all the weights for the
vertices this matrix transforms from
local space directly into bone space and
it already contains all the
transformations that go from the root
down to the bone so you don't need to
worry about the hierarchy when you use
this matrix the official documentation
says that the offset matrix transforms
from mesh space to bone space in bind
pose which is basically saying that if
you take a vertex in local space
while the model is in bind pose and you
multiply it by the offset matrix of a
bone you will get the coordinates of the
vertex in reference to that bone
this means that if two bones influence
the same vertex then by multiplying the
vertex position by the offset matrix of
each bone separately you will get two
different coordinates in reference to
the two bone spaces of course you will
need to go back from each bone to the
root and calculate a final matrix for
each bone if you transform the vertex by
the two final matrices and assuming that
both bones are moving you will get two
different positions in local space which
is why we do a weighted average of the
two final matrices to get a position
somewhere between the two bones for the
next example i've created the world's
simplest skeleton in blender with the
standard box at the origin and a single
bone which is aligned with the y-axis
which is green
as you can see the z-axis of the bone
points up which is actually the default
in blender i exported the model in this
setup to keep it simpler otherwise
blender will add transformations from
its own coordinate system to the one
that we are using and it will complicate
the analysis back to our simp sandbox
in the function par single bone i've
added a call to print smp matrix using
the m offset matrix attribute of the
bone as a parameter print smp matrix is
defined up here and it is very simple it
just prints the matrix nicely now let's
run this on the model singlebone.fbx
which is in the git repo we can see that
we're getting the identity matrix as the
offset matrix
the reason is of course that the base of
the bone is at the origin of the local
space and the axis of the bone space are
aligned with those of local space
so transforming from local space to bone
space basically means doing nothing it's
the same system let's see another
example
i've added a child bone that extends the
root bone along the y axis we can see in
blender that the root bone is located at
the origin and the end of the bone is at
one unit on the y the child bone starts
in the same location and ends at two
units on the y if we run this using the
sandbox we can see that the offset
matrix of the parent is still the
identity matrix but the offset matrix of
the child will translate us one unit
along the negative y-axis and this makes
sense because this bone space is shifted
one unit on the positive y so in order
to transform one vertex for example this
one right here which in local space is a
2 on the y to the bone space of the
child we need to subtract 1 unit from
the y because the vertex is closer to
the base of the bone than to the origin
i have one last example here called two
bones translationrotation.fbx
where the child bone has been rotated 45
degrees up and we can see that the
offset matrix of the child is very
similar to a matrix that we have
developed in the past so i will leave
this up to you as homework to explore
okay i hope that everything up until
this point made sense so we can now take
a look at the second matrix which is
located at a new section of the smp
scene this is the node hierarchy
the node represents an entity in the
scene that has a location and
orientation relative to a parent an
entity can be meshes bones and even
cameras and lighting you can actually
design an entire scene in blender and
export it with the camera and lighting
and then load it with smp i may do a
video about it in the future but for now
let's just focus on the bones the node
hierarchy starts with a single root node
and each node includes an array of
pointers to 0 or more children and an
array of pointers to 0 or more meshes
this allows you to have a single mesh in
your model file and place it in
different locations in the world using
multiple nodes as you can see it is very
simple to create the graph that we
talked about earlier using this node
structure there is also a pointer to a
single parent and a matrix called m
transformation the job of this matrix is
to transform a vector to the coordinate
system of its parent so this is like the
transformation from the coordinate
system of the earth to the coordinate
system of the sun after we multiply
position vector by the offset matrix we
find ourselves in the coordinate system
of the bone the next step is to find the
corresponding node in the graph apply
the m transformation matrix of this node
and continue all the way to the root by
traversing the parent attribute of the
node the bones are mapped to the nodes
simply using their names you search for
the name of the bone in the node
hierarchy until you find the node with
the same name let's explore the node
hierarchy using our smp sandbox in the
parse scene function i've added a call
to parse hierarchy which i will now
uncomment this function takes the scene
as a parameter and then calls parse node
using the m root node attribute of the
scene parse node prints the number of
meshes and children in the node as well
as the m transformation matrix
it then traverses the graph downwards by
recursively calling parse node on each
of its children okay so now let's test
it on the first example single bond.fbx
we can see that the root node is the
identity matrix it has two children the
cube and the armature the end
transformation matrix of the armature
switches the y and z axis and also flips
the sine of the y-coordinate
okay interesting
the armature contains a node called bone
and you can see that the
m-transformation matrix here does
exactly the reverse it switches the y
and z-axis again and flips the sign of
the z-coordinate which was previously
the y okay so they are basically
canceling each other out if we multiply
these matrices together we can verify
that we're getting the identity matrix
so i actually posted the question about
it on the smp forum and i will let you
know when i get an answer there's
actually an additional node here called
bone and which i guess is for the tail
of the bone but there isn't an actual
bone for this node so the hierarchy may
include nodes that don't have a
corresponding bone but if these nodes
have children then they will have an
effect on them and we will need to take
care of that the transformation of bone
and translates one unit on the y-axis
and this makes sense because bone and
also defines the coordinate system so if
you multiply the origin of this
coordinate system 0 0 0 by this matrix
you will get 0 1 0 which is the location
of bone end in the coordinate system of
bone so this is a trivial example but it
helps us feel how the hierarchy works
if we run this on a real model like our
good old bob lam clean we can see a much
more complex hierarchy we have the root
here then md5 hierarchy
origin pubis pelvis
spine
neck and head the transformations here
are too complex so let's just hope it
will all work out correctly
the next step is to integrate the two
matrices into our skinned mesh class
all this and more will be covered in the
next tutorial
[Music]
today we're going to integrate the two
matrices that we got introduced to in
the previous video the offset and the
transformation into our skinned mesh
class this includes two steps first we
need to transform the vertex from local
space to bone space using the offset
matrix
next we need to multiply the bone space
position by the transformation matrix of
the node and continue multiplying while
traversing all the way to the top of the
hierarchy
this will bring us back to local space
so we started in local space and we
ended up in local space so what has
changed
well basically nothing
in this tutorial we are still not
applying the animation data which is
what actually animates the model we are
just applying the bass transformations
calculated somewhere between blender and
sip so the expectation is that we will
get the model back in pause mode
now remember that in addition to the
matrices we're going to use the weights
to perform a weighted average of the
transformations so this result is far
from negligible it's an important
milestone on the way to our final
destination okay so let's review the
changes in the skinned mesh class
and we begin with skinned mesh.h
i've added a public function called get
bone transforms
this function will be called in the
render loop it basically calculates all
the transformations for all the bones
and returns them in a vector of matrices
which the color must supply as a
reference each bone has a single matrix
which we can access in the vector using
its bone id
in the final implementation this
function also takes the current time as
a parameter and then it returns a
different set of matrices in each call
based on the current posture of the
model in this tutorial we still don't
need it so i dropped it for now in the
private section i've added a function
called read node hierarchy i'll talk
more about this function when we get to
the implementation of this class i've
also added the snmp importer object and
the pointer to the aac object as private
attributes and the reason is that we
will need to access the hierarchy in the
scene during runtime when i try to do it
in the previous implementation where the
importer was local variable in the
function load mesh i got a segmentation
fault so i guess that we need to keep
the importer alive throughout the
execution and finally we have a
structure called bone info which stores
a couple of matrices we have the bone
offset matrix which is here for easy
access
final transformation
stores the intermediate results of the
whole transformation chain so that when
the entire process is complete we just
grab it from here and return it to the
application the constructor of this
class takes the offset matrix as a
parameter it stores it in the
corresponding member and it initializes
the transformation matrix to zero and of
course we also have a vector of bone
infrastructures one structure for each
bone okay so this concludes the changes
in the header as always you can compare
this file to the previous version
actually in part two because in part
three we only touch the sandbox and
you'll be able to see all of these
changes now let's take a look at the cpp
file we have a minor change in the load
mesh function
instead of the local variables for the
importer and the scene we have the new
private attributes in the class so we
will use them the next change is in the
load single bone function
after we get the bone id we check
whether it equals to the size of the
bone info vector
if this turns out to be true we know
that this is a new bone because the bone
ids are a running index in that case we
create a bone info object using the m
offset matrix from the ai bone class
remember that in addition to the weights
the simp ai bone class also has this
offset matrix
after we initialize the bone info object
we push it into the vector
this means that we can access the bone
information using the bone index at the
bottom of this file we have the two new
functions first we have get bone
transforms which takes a reference to a
vector of matrices we start by resizing
this vector using the number of bone
infrastructures that we have
next we initialize a local matrix to be
the identity matrix and we call read
node hierarchy using the root node of
the scene and this matrix after read
node hierarchy returns we should have
the transformations that we need in the
final transformation member of the bone
info vector so all we need to do is to
copy these matrices to the vectors
supplied by the caller now let's take a
look at the read node hierarchy function
which is a bit tricky because it is a
recursive function
it takes a pointer to an ai node object
and a reference to a parent matrix the
first call to this function is done
using the root node of the hierarchy and
the identity matrix we start by creating
a node transformation matrix using the m
transformation matrix from the node
next we create a global transformation
matrix by multiplying the parent matrix
with this matrix
so we are actually traversing the graph
from top to bottom rather than from the
node back to the root because this
global matrix is going to be used in the
calculation of all of its children so by
going from top to bottom we can
calculate it only once
note that we're taking advantage of the
associativity nature of matrix
multiplication that tells us
that as long as we keep the order of the
matrices we can change the location of
the parentheses next we check if we have
a bone that matches the name of the node
all the bones have a corresponding node
in the hierarchy but there may be nodes
without bones we already have a map
between bone names and their indices so
this is very easy to do if we find such
a bone we update its final
transformation to be the result of
multiplying its offset matrix by the
global matrix
which basically captures the entire
chain from the node back to the root
finally we traverse the children of the
current node and we call read node
hierarchy recursively on each child node
with the global transformation matrix in
the second parameter so as we go deeper
into the graph this global
transformation encapsulates more and
more m transformation matrices let's
take a look at the changes in the
application code and this is very simple
in the render function we define a
vector of matrices we get the bond
transformations from the mesh and we
loop over the vector that we got back we
set the matrices into the skinning
technique one by one this is a very
simple function that updates the uniform
array in the shader so i'll skip it and
you can take a look at it later the last
change is in the vertex shader we have a
new uniform called g-bones this is an
array of 100 matrices so make sure this
is enough for the models that you plan
to load in the main function we create a
bond transfer matrix as a weighted
average of the matrices of all the bones
that influence the current vertex we use
the bone ids of the vertex to access the
bone uniform array take a look at part 2
if you don't remember where the bone ids
came from each bone matrix is multiplied
by the corresponding weight which is
also a vertex attribute if the number of
bones is less than 4 the weights will be
0 so the calculation will have no effect
we sum up the results of all these
multiplications to get the final bone
transformation and we use it to
transform the vertex from local space
back into local space again once we
integrate the animation data the
position will be different than the
original the shader continues as usual
by multiplying the updated local
position
by the wvp matrix there is actually no
change in the fragment shader so this
concludes this video
the next step is to integrate the
animation data so we can finally see
something moving
all this and more will be covered in the
next tutorial
[Music]
welcome to the fifth
and final part of the skeletal animation
tutorial miniseries
okay so basically this means that we
need to get the animation working by the
end of this video but first let's do a
quick checkup of what we already know
about the relevant snmp data structures
the ai scene class has a list of meshes
and each mesh has a list of bones for
each bone in addition to the weights and
the offset matrix we also have a
corresponding node in the node hierarchy
the node has a transformation matrix
that gets us to the coordinate system of
its parent in the previous tutorial we
saw how these two matrices work together
so make sure to watch that video first
the icin class
also has an array of ai animation
structures each structure represents a
full animation sequence such as running
fighting or whatever the character can
do
there are a couple of time related
attributes in this structure we have m
duration which is the length of the
animation in tix
and m ticks per second which is
basically the intended frame rate of the
animation set by the artist so for
example if the frame rate is 30 and your
game is running at 60 frames per second
you will need to interpolate an extra
frame between two consecutive animation
frames and vice versa if the game is
slower than the animated model we will
need to skip frames to keep up the
intended pace of the animation obviously
if we divide the duration by ticks per
second we get the length of the
animation in actual seconds the most
important attribute in ai animation is
an array of ai node anom structures
called m channels the size of the array
is given in m num channels each animated
node in the hierarchy has a
corresponding entry in this array so if
we go into the declaration of ai node
anim we can see that it has a member
called m node name
in order to find the animation data for
a specific node in the hierarchy we just
need to find its name in the m channels
array the animation parameters
themselves are given in three separate
arrays
position and scaling are given in
vectors and the rotation is a quaternion
each array can theoretically have a
different length which is why we have
non-position keys num rotation keys and
num scaling keys in our example we have
140 position and rotation entries and no
scaling
the code must be flexible to handle all
the available cases ai vector key and ai
quad key are actually a pair of
attributes that represent the
transformation and the time in ticks in
which this transformation should take
place the keys are guaranteed to be
sorted in their chronological orders so
searching for the current time simply
means traversing the array until we find
the time range between two consecutive
keys in which the current time is
located assuming that the current time
will usually land
between two keys we must interpolate
between the animation parameters of
these two keys after we interpolate the
animation parameters we combine the
scaling rotation and translation into a
single transformation matrix and that
basically it
so now let's jump into the code and see
how to actually implement it
this time i'd like to start in the
application code where we have a minor
change and that is the tracking of time
i've added a new private attribute for
the start time in milliseconds and when
we are finished with the init function
we initialize it by calling
getcurrenttime in millis this function
is defined in common oglwdevutel.cpp
and you can see that we actually have a
different implementation for windows and
linux
on windows we use getty account and on
linux we use get time of day
both of these functions are very simple
and you can check out the documentation
on your own for more details
now there are also high resolution
timers that you can use if you need more
precision but i'm okay with the
millisecond level okay so in the render
function we just need to call get
current time in millis again and
calculate the delta between the startup
time and the current time and that will
give us the time that the application
has been running
notice that we divide the result by a
thousand here and cast it to float so we
get the animation time in seconds with
possible fractions between seconds
we provide the animation time to get
bone transforms
so that we can calculate the correct
transformations for the current point in
time
okay so while recording i forgot to tell
you that get bone transforms needs to
convert the time in seconds into ticks
because snmp specifies the start time
for each frame in ticks
we do this by multiplying the time in
seconds by the number of ticks per
second the ticks per second can be found
in the ai animation structure and in
case it was not set by the modeling
software we set it to 25 by default
which is simply the value that i saw in
the smp sources the next step depends on
the logic of your game
if you want to run the animation
sequence once you need to reset the
start time at the point where the
animation is supposed to start
in this demo i want the animation to run
again and again so i'm using f mode to
do a floating point modular operation of
the current timing ticks and the
duration of the animation this divides
the entire execution of the demo into
segments of m duration length and in the
animation timing ticks we get the
current time within that segment
now let's jump directly into the
implementation of the skinned mesh class
and in part 3 i mentioned the global
inverse transform so i want to talk
about it for a second the idea is that
in some models that are loaded by simp
the transformation matrix of the root
node may actually be
the wall transformation of the object
this allows you to place the object in
the world
already in blender in that case we need
to bring the object back into local
space
apply the animation in local space and
then transform the object
back to wherever you want it to be in
order to do that we need to reverse the
transformation of the root node and
apply it at the end of the entire
transformation chain so after we load
the model we grab the m transformation
matrix of the root node we store it in a
new private attribute called m global
inverse transform and we call the
inverse function in order to inverse
this matrix the inverse function is
defined in math3d.cpp
and this is a standard implementation of
matrix inversion which you can find in
many resources online so no big deal
here the global inverse transform is
used in the read node hierarchy function
you can see that i've added it to the
head of the transformation chain so
the final transformation of a bone is
first the offset matrix to go from local
space to bone space
then we have the global transform which
captures
all the node transformations to the root
of the hierarchy and finally the inverse
global matrix okay i hope this makes
sense now let's jump back to the top of
this function we get the animation time
in seconds as a parameter from the
application the next thing we need to do
is to access the animation sequence that
we're interested in
in this tutorial i'm keeping it simple
so i use the first animation
by default but if you know that your
model has several animations you can
search for the one you want in the m
animation array next we need to search
inside the ai animation structure for
the ai node anim that matches the
current node and we do this in the find
node anim function which is defined
right here it takes the ai animation
structure and the name of the node and
it simply traverses the channels in the
animation until it finds the one that
matches the name of the node in that
case it returns the matching ai node
anim structure
not all nodes are animated and in that
case we return null
back to read node hierarchy if a node
animation data was found we calculate
the transformation matrix for the
animation we're going to cover the
calculation in just a bit but before we
do that i want you to pay attention to
something which is very important
when the current node has animation data
we override the node transformation
matrix which was initially initialized
by the end transformation matrix from
the graph and the explanation for that
can be found in the documentation that
tells us
that the transformation matrix computed
from these values
replaces the node's original
transformation matrix at a specific time
this means all keys are absolute and not
relative to the bone default pose
okay so if you expected the animation
matrix to be applied on top of the node
transformation that is not the case if
the node is not animated we continue the
process with the transformation matrix
from the graph but if it does have
animation we have to override this
matrix with the one that we're going to
calculate so we want to be careful here
otherwise we'll get garbage
the transformation matrix of the
animation is calculated by initializing
three separate matrices for the scaling
rotation and translation and combining
them as usual into a single matrix for
example let's see how the scaling matrix
is calculated we prepare a vector for
the scaling and notice that i'm using
the smp vector structure here ai vector
3d
we call calc interpolated scaling with
the scaling vector the animation time
and the node animation structure
this function starts by checking the
number of scaling keys that we have if
there is only one key there is no room
for any interpolation so we just return
the value of the first key
if there is more than one key we need to
find a key that matches the current time
the keys are sorted by time so we need
to find the first key whose time is
greater than the current time and we
need to interpolate between that key and
the one just before that to do that we
have fine scaling which traverses all
the scaling keys in the ai node anime
structure and compares the current time
to the time in the key
notice that the for loop starts at zero
and stops at one key before the end
because we're actually checking the key
at i plus one and if the animation time
is smaller than that time we return the
index i back to calc interpolated
scaling once we have the index of the
correct key the next index is the one
that we found plus one we have to
interpolate between these two keys and
this is standard linear interpolation we
calculate the delta time between the two
keys and the interpolation factor is the
range between the beginning of the time
range that we found and the current time
divided by the length of the range
itself so this will give us a factor
between 0 and 1 depending on how close
we are to the edges of the range okay so
if we're very close to the beginning the
factor will be close to zero and if
we're almost at the end the factor will
be close to one the way that we actually
use the factor
is by grabbing the scaling vectors from
the two indices calculating the range
between them and then the result is the
starting value plus the product of the
factor and the delta
okay so this allows us to smoothly
interpolate between the scaling vectors
especially when the game is running at a
higher frame rate than what the model
was originally designed for going back
to read node hierarchy you can see that
we used the interpolated scaling vector
to initialize the standard scaling
matrix calculating the interpolated
rotation and translation is exactly the
same the only thing worth mentioning
here is that interpolating the two
quaternions is done using the simp
interpolate function which is part of
the ai quaternion class we also
normalize the quaternion before we
return it to the color we combine the
three transformation matrices together
in the standard order which you can also
see in the documentation
scaling rotation and then translation
and that's it
[Music]
so this completes the mini series on
skeletal animation
i hope you enjoyed it as much as i did
please hit the like button subscribe
feel free to comment below and i'll see
you in the next tutorial
[Music]
you